it's the biggest fire of occupied
dwellings
that massive fire that destroyed an area
of downtown sunday now being compared to
a wildfire sally jaramillo is near
charleston and fremont where today crews
were going through that rubble again
sally
denise as you can imagine a very scary
situation for residents who are just
trying to protect their family members
and their homes now today fire crews
still were out here trying to determine
what caused the blaze
that was 50 units from around the valley
with 150 fire personnel on scene tim
samanski with las vegas fire and rescue
tells me he can only think of two to
three times in the valley where they had
an alarm this big these people are
coming out there's glowing fire it's
dark it's real smoky there's people
screaming it was really scary for them
and lives were saved when fire crews
noticed something smoldering in that
area one of our units station 4 unit was
returning the quarters around 16th and
charleston he was at maryland in
charleston he saw a column of smoke says
i'm going to run down here and
investigate it he came down here and as
soon as he was passing by here on
charleston they could see the building
fully involved fire and rescue
investigators as well as the clark
county fire department agents from
alcohol tobacco firearms and explosives
and even an arson dog are looking for
clues to what started the blaze the dog
did not hit on anything there's nothing
that is at this point that is looking
suspicious semanski also tells me there
is a lot of homeless in the area and
fireworks fire is serious business and i
think people are waking up to that all
over the united states now
back out live investigators are also
going to take a look at the records
related to the building to see if there
could be anything that may have started
this for now reporting live in downtown
las vegas sally jaramillo live local now